[Music]
teamwork leads to greater efficiency
whatever be the job a complete set of
people in coordination can make it
possible but a team is usually
considered incomplete without a leader a
leader is the one who not only guides
but even regulates or controls the
working of other team members the same
analogy can be used to study the
cellular organelles the various
organelles are like the in charge of
specific functions and can you guess who
acts like the leader here it's the
nucleus you heard me right the nucleus
is the controlling unit for every
organelle located right at the centre of
the cell it governs the functions of the
other organelles but how does it
regulate the activities of other
organelles
let's try finding it out in this video
the reason why nucleus is given the
status of the major cell organelle is
because it contains the genetic material
of the organism now what could this
genetic material be if we zoom in this
nucleus we find these tangled thread
like structures any idea what these
structures are these are called the
chromatin fibers are they important to
us in any way well they are the most
important component of the nucleus and
even that completes cell because these
chromatin fibers enclose the genetic
material within them when the cell has
to divide these long threads coil
themselves to form a sophisticated and
compact structure called the chromosome
we have come across this term often it
looks somewhat like this these
chromosomes are made up of smaller
important segments these functional
units are called genes genes form the
basis of heredity in all organisms that
means the similarities and variations
that organisms have with their parents
for example what do friends and family
say when they see a baby she looks
exactly like
her mother or she's so much like her
father that's because the newborn baby
gets her genes from her parents now
let's zoom in a bit more any idea what
these functional segments named genes
are made up of genes are made up of
molecules of DNA you heard me right
deoxyribonucleic acid abbreviated as DNA
forms the genes so now if we go in the
reverse manner then we have DNA
molecules forming functional segments
called genes many such genes come
together to form the chromosomes
however the compact chromosomal
structure exists only when the cell is
about to divide so usually when the cell
is in the resting or the active face
part from cell division the chromosomes
exist as tangled threads called
chromatin in other words chromosomes and
chromatin are the same thing the genetic
material is locked in the form of these
chromatin threads present in the nucleus
now this was about why the nucleus is
called the major organelle but any idea
how the system of regulation works well
that happens with the help of proteins
the genes present in the nucleus code
for specific proteins these proteins
perform various functions that we find
in the cell so functions right from
passing information communication or
even building structures all these are
carried out by the specific proteins
that is how the nucleus helps in
regulating the various functions of the
other cell organelles unlike the other
organelles even the nucleus has its own
membrane that separates the inner
contents from the rest of the cytoplasm
the membrane however has pores to allow
entry and exit of substances across it
also the nucleus has its own nucleoplasm
that is slightly different from the rest
of the cytoplasm
now that we've learned about the ruling
organelle in the cell
let's deviate towards the other working
organelles as well let's try learning
about the remaining organelles in our
upcoming videos
[Music]
you